ja mit diesem spiel angeschaut und ich
komme zu einem klaren schluss die cdu
muss sich jetzt sofort schleunigst aus
der regierung zurück ziehen man kann
sich in der heutigen zeit nicht nur zu
tode amüsieren man kann sich auch zu
tode regieren und das ist das problem
diese cdu die cdu ist nach 16 jahren an
der macht gott keine richtige partei
mehr eine partei ist in der politik eine
gruppe von leuten die für etwas
bestimmtes partei ergreift aber die cdu
die merkel-cdu die ist für alles und sie
ist dafür das gegenteil ist total
beliebig das ist unglaublich wenn man
sich gegen irgendetwas
abgrenzt und wenn diese cdu an der macht
bleibt dann wird sie sich nicht lösen
können von dieser
merkelschen linksverschiebung vermerk
übrigens auch das bürgerliche lager
gespalten man hat die
unzufriedenen cdu wähler in die afg
getrieben dadurch ist die linke gestärkt
wurden also die cdu muss in der
opposition gesunden und die cdu muss
dann wieder werden was es heute in
deutschland ich gibt nämlich eine partei
der wirklichkeit wir haben zu viele
politische traumtänzer deshalb plädiere
ich dafür jetzt übergibt die macht den
linken und den roten das wird zwar eine
rette sich wer kann mentalität auslösen
viele deutsche werden in die schweiz
kommen herzlich willkommen aber diese
cdu muss in die opposition und sie muss
in der opposition gesund sei werde es
auch wirklich
muss direkt in der sprechen ich glaube
auch dass die cdu einen anderen weg
einschlagen muss ich glaube auch dass
die cdu viele hinter sich gelassen hat
durch die art der politik ist war nicht
mehr die konservative politik in den
punkten stimme ich überein
aber was würde jetzt passieren wenn wir
sagen wir mal urs case kommt wir haben
rot-rot-grün
was würde dann passieren ich glaube
nicht dass die enttäuschten cdu wähler
oder die eh schon zurückgelassen wurden
zurückkehren zur cdu ich glaube es wird
der nächste schlag kommen und die gehen
zu afd und deswegen habe ich ganz große
angst jetzt vor einer linken regierung
weil ich nicht das szenario mir
vorstellen kann dass sie dann zurück zur
in der opposition tätigen cdu gehen
sondern dass sie zu afd gehen und darf
ab und wenn die berggipfel dass sie auch
stand also gewerkschaft abschaffen und
gleichzeitig rot-rot-grün das
schließlich auch um wie aus also das
kriegen wir auch die wenigsten haben und
was uns hier einig in der tiefe geht es
geht nämlich darum dass deutschland ja
im moment gar keine chance mehr hat eine
bürgerliche politik zu bekommen weil
frau merkel die cdu so weit nach links
verschoben hat dass rechts von der cdu
das passiert ist was gemäss franz josef
strauß gar nicht hätte passieren dürfen
nämlich die entstehung einer partei die
rechts von der cdu steht das heißt das
bürgerliche lager ist gespalten weil
frau merkel
und statt den fehler einzugestehen
gesagt hat diese idee ist eine
nazi-partei obwohl sie von sehr vielen
unzufriedenen cd banken gewährt wie aber
verkaufen wären eine gerade schweren
jungs hier eigentlich ein wahnsinn war
er glauben wir ein geklautes
bürgerliches lagerung die cdu weiß nicht
mehr wer sie ist sie muss sich zuerst
selber wieder finden und sie muss sich
in der opposition wieder fehler haben
sie in der region und die hydrierung
eine extreme entwicklung auch endlich
sehen dass er gerade bock haben die
gegründet wurde von professoren die
angetreten sind um die euro politik zu
kritisieren hin zu einer partei die nun
erkennbar auch viele viele
rechtsextremen will ja in sich hat aber
lassen sie mich in anderen punkt
vielleicht noch ganz kurz machen um auf
das einzugehen eigentlich hat ihre idee
in gewisser weise scham zu sagen eine
partei nach 16 jahren hat aus regiert
ist aus regiert ist ausgelaugt und muss
sich deshalb regenerieren ich glaube
bloß dass die alternativen und das hast
du auch gerade angesprochen die sind ja
nicht besser die spd ist auch ausgelaugt
die spd regiert mit kleinster
unterbrechung von vier jahren sei 998
total ausgelaugt da war der erste erst
fc kaiserslautern so und am meisten da
will ich nämlich mal ein punkt machen
willi weber kommt ja aus kaiserslautern
wie ich erfahren habe und da haben wir
ein problem wenn die cdu freiwillig in
die opposition geht das käme einem
abstieg meiner meinung nach gleich um
jetzt mal den schlag zum sport zu machen
und wir haben vielfach erlebt dass
traditionsvereine die abgestiegen sind
sie eben nicht geschafft haben gestärkt
wieder der programm lautern hat es
einmal geschafft tatsächlich als meister
aber dann ging es auch rasend schnell
wieder bergab diese mittlerweile in der
dritten liga und weg vom kuchen ich
glaube nicht dass eine selbstreinigung
nur in der opposition stattfinden kann
wobei ich den gedanken auch spannend
finde wenn das ergebnis nicht
automatisch sein muss dass wir das
komplette gegenteil umschlagen rot grün
habe glauben glauben sie nicht wenn
jetzt eine linke regierung das zepter
übernimmt die hat ja jetzt eigentlich
auch eine linke
auch eine linke regierung geführt von
einer cdu frauen 1 dann das hat doch
auch eine therapeutische wirkung und die
deutschen umlaute was dann hier über
eine politik kommt wenn die linken
übernehmen aber ich sage die cdu kinder
macht neigt dazu ihre seele zu vergessen
den totalen innerlichen ausverkauf zu
betreiben und die ofd wir müssen nicht
darüber diskutieren dass es doch höchst
fragwürdige leute gibt aber die ofd die
entstehung der ofd ist ein symptom dafür
dass etwas mit der cdu fundamental
falsch ist und ich bin der das auch die
cdu hat eine riesige zukunft aber nicht
als partei des pseudo linken traumtänzer
tun sondern aus partei der wirklichkeit
die wieder das macht was die deutschen
wollen die deutschen sind nach meinem
verständnis ein extrem wirklichkeit
bezogenes folgt die leute arbeiten ihr
die wohnung keinen politischen druck
herkömmlich dass die cdu nach sieben
jahren opposition zwischen 98 und 2005
als die bürgerliche kraft zurück er dass
die sage ja gerade genau das gegenteil
ihren dass angela merkel in ihrer
kanzlerschaft die cdu eigentlich weiter
nach links geschoben hat das weiß ich
glaube von der theorie her an die
selbstheilung und reinigungskräfte auch
um sich neu zu besinnen und auch starke
persönlichkeiten aufzubauen aber wir
haben erkannt bei der cdu mag das nicht
jeder so gar nicht geklappt dieses ost
berlin eher so aus das ist eine
ferndiagnose aus der schweiz wohlwollend
betrachtet was ist das problem der
deutschen politik aus bürgerlich
liberaler sicht das problem ist dass sie
keine bürgerliche kraft haben jetzt im
land die das ganze bürgerliche lager
vereinigen und sie haben ein gespaltenes
lages können sie sagen die häufte selbst
die extremisten aber tatsache ist auf
der linken seite haben sie rot dunkelrot
die spannen zusammen und die grünen sind
im prinzip auch rot also wenn sie an
einem grünen kratzen dann wird es dann
sehr schnell laut und ja es kommt sehr
schnell
und deshalb muss sich die cdu
bewegen die ofd muss sich auch irgendwie
neu erfinden und dann muss dieses
bürgerliche lager wieder aus der
opposition auch der selbstfindung diese
linken in die defensive zwingen das ist
ein szenario und ich kann euch sagen
dass wir funktionieren aber eine cdu die
an der macht bleibt die wirtin diesem
rot-grünen wo viel mainstream schaum
baut ihre konturen ihr profil und am
schluss gänzlich ihre seele verlieren
und hat sich gesehen herr laschet wird
ja schon kritisiert weil er sich von den
linken abgrenzt ja was ja auch
unglaubwürdig ist mir was ich gesehen
habe interesse riesig er herrkoerper die
die geschichte spricht ein bisschen
dagegen denken sie an den leipziger
parteitag der cdu und wie gut dass am
ende in anführungsstrichen gut dass am
ende geklappt hat angela merkel hat die
wahl 2005 haarscharf gewonnen und ist
dann reingegangen in die regierung mit
dem mit dem festen wissen ich kann mich
eigentlich gar nicht richtig als
bürgerliche neue kraft etablieren
möglicherweise wollen die deutschen das
gar nicht so sehr ich glaube die
deutschen wollen etwas anderes diese
politik auch nicht als harte
auseinandersetzung beispielsweise ein
box kam wo man wirklich sich torjäger
die sehen das als kaffeeklatsch im
wohnzimmer es muss gemütlich sein es
muss gemütlich sagt was voller bilder
zieren regeln chef und zwar sicherlich
hoch interessant wenn sie das
wahlprogramm der cdu 2005 anschauen also
das was man damals versprochen hat dann
ist ja das interessante dass frau merkel
zum teil das gegenteil von dem gemacht
hat was die cdu damals versprochen zum
beispiel stärkung der kernenergie man
hat gesagt steuern senken
staatsverschuldung senken staatsquote
schiefgegangen angela merke man hat ihn
allen bereichen die ziele nicht
umgesetzt und das bereits etwas anderes
für mich nicht ob sich eine partei
regenieren regenerieren kann das zeigt
einfach aus deutsche wähler darfst du
nicht glauben was dir die politikerin an
wenn du glaubst du denn dass man zurück
zu afd gilt also ich glaube eher dass
sie dass sie wlan nicht zur cdu zurück
klein werden sondern dass wenn wir eine
tiefe linke regierung haben dass sie
sich der afg zuwende extremer die eine
seite desto mehr geht man dann ins
andere extrem um sie auszugleichen
glaube ich auch und ich finde wenn die
cdu raus das heißt es ja nicht
automatisch rot rot grün also ampel zum
beispiel wer auch noch möglich ich weiß
nicht ob rot rot grün jetzt dann das
einzige szenario ist was uns da ein feld
sollte es so sein mir graut ein bisschen
vor noch mal quasi große koalition mit
noch fdp dabei oder so also ich find's
ganz ganz schwierig wenn cdu und spd
sich noch mal zusammen tut er wird uns
leid aber noch nach wer wird kanzler
drei wochen knapp drei wochen mal also
seit einer woche denke ich im abseits
herr köppel
also ich muss sagen ich wünsche
deutschland nicht rot rot grün also ich
fände das natürlich wer nicht gut ob ich
denke zwar lasse sich der cdu wer wie
kommst du ich glaube aber ich bestehe
auf verlorenem posten los tatsächlich
noch am besten gemacht also lag ich
kanzler du kannst du sagen sie lachend
kanzler und eine sache mächtigen kali
ganz kurz und 101 holz das eigentlich
abwendet und sich klar distanziert von
den ganz roten auf der linken seite dann
glaube ich in der tat wird laschet das
ding aber nur noch rumreißen hat er
kommt sogar ein
niemand hat mehrfach gesagt aber ich
sage auch nicht
wir haben ich würde ich sagen lasse
trendwende kommt morgen als wir glauben
dass mit jan lindner noch kleine
hoffnungen hat am ende des tages noch
unter schock ich glaube nicht dass er
ganze wird dann gottes nun aber ich
glaube die fdp wird sehr auch um gottes
willen hat ja ich werde mir das knie
frechheit dass jetzt wirklich noch über
trelle nachgedacht wird wenn man sieht
wo grüne und fdp steht also ich muss
sagen der öffentlich rechtliche rundfunk
vor allem muss christian lindner dazu
bitten ich glaube ich glaube da hätte
zeit sei nicht zu machen nebenher machen
echt er wäre nicht einen sehr sehr guten
wahlkampf muss man sagen und was sie bei
zu laschen auch sagen möchte ich habe
letztens in einem hohen spitzenpolitiker
der cdu telefoniert und dann hat er zu
mir gesagt den spruch ich gerne in
teilen der ohne hat er gesagt dass armin
laschet ein wahnsinnig schlechter
wahlkampf ist aber ein wahnsinn ein
guter kanzler wäre weil er ein
teamplayer hilfe weil er kein ich
menschen und dann habe ich in dem moment
gedacht aber das ist doch das was man
will
[Musik]